At the center of AI is data,
it powers everything.
And at Microsoft,
we have unique data graphs.
World knowledge with Bing and
work knowledge with the rest
of the Microsoft graph.
But really the magic
happens when you make sense
of all this information.
We've evolved from
simple searches and
keyword matching to using
advanced AI techniques,
like machine reading
comprehension that uses deep
learning to understand
the meaning behind words.
We also need really
powerful hardware in order
to process these AI models,
like deep neural networks.
We've partnered with Intel to
create industry leading agility
and performance with FPGA chips
that allow us to read and
understand billions of
documents in milliseconds.
So how does this apply
to you every day?
Today, I'm gonna show you how
AI enables intelligent search
in a few ways.
One with intelligent answers,
Bing for
business, intelligent
image search, and
a new search paradigm that is
for more conversational search.
Let's start with
something rather mundane,
like finding a movie to
watch for the holidays.
So inside of a simple keyword
search, I'm gonna use something
with more natural language,
like movies directed by
Spielberg starring Tom Hanks,
let's use Tom Hanks.
Okay, this answer is
specific to my actual query.
It filtered out TV shows and
their other partnerships, but
it still included a movie
that they're doing
together in January.
With Bing's vast understanding
of the world, people and
entities, and
how they relate to each other,
AI enables us to power more
rich and complete answers.
Now let's say I'm doing
research on something
a bit more controversial.
I'm a vegan and I take a lot
of plaque from my family for
being an annoying kill pusher.
I wanna be prepared for
the inevitable holiday table
debate with my cousin.
So I'm gonna do a search for
facts about Kale.
This result here is
a multi-source answer.
Bing uses AI to bring
together information from
multiple different
websites into one place.
And at Microsoft, we believe
it's important to understand
where information comes from.
So although we provide quick
access and links to content,
we're also really careful to
ensure we also include sources.
So this way I can feel confident
about my advocacy of kale.
And if I want to be
super prepared and
understand both sides of
an issue, because we don't
live in a world of absolutes,
I can do a query like,
also using natural language
like, is kale good for you?
This is a multi-perspective
answer.
Bing shows alternate viewpoints,
so
that you can understand
both sides of an issue.
So on one side I have pro kale
and on the other side I have
a cautionary tale of why
too much kale is bad.
So that I don't have
to live in a bubble,
where everything about
kale is amazing.
And if I really wanna embrace
this kale loving lifestyle,
I should probably take
up yoga or pilates.
But I don't actually really know
the difference between them.
So if I do a search for,
difference between yoga and
pilates, I get this
comparison answer.
Bing has taken comparisons
a feature typically found
in product or
shopping based scenarios, and
have expanded it to
a wider query set.
We use machine reading
comprehension to read the web
and understand entities and
their aspects,
in order to compare
differences between items.
So this yoga seems like
it's more of my jam, so
let's go ahead and
just pick that.
And I've heard a lot about yoga
retreats in Costa Rica, but
I don't actually have a sense
for how big is Costa Rica.
This is a relational answer.
In addition to showing
the actual square miles,
I'm also told it's about twice
the size of Massachusetts,
which is incidentally
my home state.
So I have a good sense
of what that means.
Bing has used AI and add some
perspective into information, so
not only we're using AI to
search across the billions
of documents in the web,
we're also using AI to make
information more understandable.
Because while the engineer may
geeks out of all this data,
the designer only knows that
real user delight comes from
making data make sense.
So all of these new experiences,
multiple sources,
multiple perspectives,
comparisons, and relational
answers, they all make up what
we call intelligent answers.
So all of these everyday AI
capabilities are awesome, but
what if we could apply them
to the context of work.
That's exactly what we've
done with Bing for Business.
For starters, let me just go
back to the Bing homepage.
Because I'm signed in with
my Microsoft work account,
at the bottom of my home page,
I can see industry related news
that's relevant to me,
a person in tech.
And beyond this personalization,
let me show you what
the Microsoft graph and
AI can do for
workplace productivity.
So I have a Microsoft
holiday party coming up,
and the fabulous Harry Shum is
my executive vice president.
So because I'm signed in and I
have Bing for Business enabled,
I type in Harry's org.
And note that I'm not using his
last name, but it still provides
me with the org chart for the
right Harry, even though there
are plenty of great Harry's
that work at Microsoft.
Also in the same experience web
results that are related to
the query Harris org.
So Bing for
Business brings together
the best of corporate Internet
search with the best of web
search all into one experience.
So if I do something a little
bit more complicated like,
how much vacation do I get?
Because of the FPGA chip,
I get answers in milliseconds.
And if it's for
something super obscure,
I can search for,
can I hire a cousin?
Machine reading comprehension
powers this answer.
What you'll notice here is that
cousin isn't even mentioned
in the passage.
That's because Bing knows that
cousin is a family member and
understands the meaning
behind words to give me
the right answer.
Not that I would hire my
kale-hating cousin anyway.
So for this holiday party,
I'm also gonna wanna find
something festive to wear.
But it is a work event,
so I'm gonna search for
work appropriate
holiday cocktail dress.
And I'm gonna go to image,
our image vertical.
And then, this one looks
appropriately festive.
Bing intelligent image
uses computer vision,
an AI technique, in order
to find dresses that look
just like this one with
direct links to buy.
So that I can look around and
do some price comparisons.
And the other thing it does, is
our object detection allows me
to rescope this query
on just this necklace.
So now I can find necklaces that
look very similar to one in this
photo, again with
direct links to buy.
Bing is intelligent search
that saves time and money.
Okay, in addition to Intelligent
Answers, Bing for Business, and
Intelligent Image Search,
we're also using AI
to make the search box itself
more conversational with
an interactive guided
search experience.
We hear a lot from customers
that they wish search
could just complete
their sentences.
If I do a vague search like,
I'm feeling stressed,
which may or
may not be because of this demo.
I get this guided
search experience.
So I get obviously the web
results you'd expect from
a search engine.
I get our answers, but then
up top, what you'll see here
is that it prompts for
additional career refinements.
So I can go through and
pick stress management and
then breathing exercises, and
then I can also kind of expand
to see previous results.
What's different here is
that search is building upon
the last search.
So it's a little bit
more conversational,
a little bit more personalized.
We're able to do with this is
get you better answers faster.
This is a new search paradigm.
We are amplifying our extensive
knowledge graph with AI.
Our expertise in conversational
AI with our bots like and
Zoe are brought together
with our vast data,
enables Bing to create a new
interactive search experience
that gets you better
answers faster.
If I do another example for,
let's see,
Seattle verse, I'm prompted for
popular rivalries.
So I'm gonna select
the Rams here.
And then here you'll see
an answer of an upcoming
game on the 17th.
In addition to web links and
this awesome answer, I can also
see who Bing predicts to win.
So we're predicting that
the Rams will win by 51%.
Bing uses search, social and
other relevant data signals in
order to make predictions on
sports, reality TV shows and
more.
And if I do another
really ambiguous search,
like set default.
Without any context of what
default I'm trying to set,
I'm prompted with
very popular things
that people set default for.
Conversational search uses
large-scale machine learning, so
this experience is only
gonna get better over time.
AI learns from user engagement,
so we're really excited for
the future of
conversational search.
What I've shown you today,
Intelligent Answers, Bing for
Business, Intelligent
Image Search, and
a new conversational guided
search is just a small sampling
of how we are using AI to
create intelligent search.
All of these experiences
are either live today or
starting to roll out today.